[Música]
nuestra con nuestra primera invitada del
día vamos a hablar de la situación de
los venezolanos o migrantes ahora
parados en México tras la decisión de
Estados Unidos de llevar a cabo una
deportación inmediata a quienes intentan
cruzar por la frontera terrestre Cuál es
el papel de México en todo este acuerdo
pues lo vamos a hablar con Daisy el real
ella es el profesora asistente de
sociología en la University of sardin
California research experta en migración
internacional Gracias Daisy por estar
con nosotros esta mañana de jueves en
directo América la situación de los
venezolanos varados en México y Panamá
no principalmente pero hablemos de la
situación en México donde se concentra
la mayoría Quienes no pudieron pasar a
Estados Unidos por esta política
implementada por el presidente Joe biden
Buenos días Muchas gracias por la
invitación Raúl Mira para entender a lo
que está pasando con México y como las
decisiones de Estados Unidos impacta
México es importante entender también lo
que ha estado siendo México con los
venezolanos en los últimos años inicial
México inicialmente México acogía a los
venezolanos de forma mucho más receptiva
a no les exigía visado y los lo que los
dejaban los venezolanos entrar a México
y solicitar asilo de forma más fácil
también México es uno de los pocos
países en Latinoamérica que extiende el
asilo a través de la definición de la
declaración de Cartagena la cual designa
como refugiados a personas que huyen de
un contexto de violencia generalizado a
conflicto interno violaciones masivas de
derechos humanos y en la alteración del
orden público para los mexicanos que
solicitaron asilo en la tasa de
aprobación era bastante alta
desafortunadamente bajo la presión del
gobierno estadounidense las autoridades
mexicanas están restringiendo sus
políticas migratorias para impedir la
entrada de los inmigrantes venezolanos y
venezolanas en su frontera sur y hacia
su frontera norte con Estados Unidos
sí como
de eso de eso le quería preguntar no
hace dos días también Estados Unidos
pues se dijo que ya no iba a seguir
implementando el programa quédate en
México para precisamente eso no que
México también funcione como un tercer
país seguro pero realmente es México un
país de seguridad para los migrantes
mira en realidad no porque no se sabe
muy bien Qué es lo que le va a pasar a
los por ejemplo con Este título 24 que
antes a México sólo aceptaba
guatemaltecos hondureños y salvadoreños
ahora lo está extendiendo para aceptar a
venezolanos que son deportados de forma
escrita de Estados Unidos
no está claro Cuántos tiempos los
venezolanos se van a poder quedar en en
México y si van a poder recibir ahí hay
algunos informes que dicen que los
venezolanos tienen como siete días les
dan un documento que les dicen tiene
siete días para salir de México a
quedarse en México no les están dando
residencia legal no les están
necesariamente dando ingreso a vivienda
comida acceso al cuidado México o
dejando que sus hijos ingresen a la
escuela para poder hacer varios de estas
cosas se necesita tramitar la residencia
legal para sacar documentos de
identificación mexicanos lo que esto no
nos está aportando los venezolanos
entonces también el presidente mexicano
López Obrador dijo que no aceptaría más
de 24 mil venezolanos que sean
deportados o expulsados de forma
expedita de Estados Unidos Entonces
cuando llegues a casa no se sabe que va
a pasar a entonces
están los venezolanos ahorita en México
están en una situación muy vulnerable
los que son expulsados y también los que
están tratando a a cruzar México o
quedarse en México sí políticas de
retorno que pudiera implantar el
gobierno mexicano en conversaciones con
el venezolano para tratar pues de alguna
manera de volver a estos migrantes que
están varados sin dinero y pues sin
ninguna condición digamos digna de vida
no en el territorio mexicano por este
impedimento del paso hacia Estados
Unidos lo pudiéramos ver este
acercamiento entre el gobierno mexicano
y venezolano para emprender
una ley o no sé un programa para
devolverlos a Venezuela
yo creo que sí se puede hacer a
Venezuela ha hecho esto especialmente
durante la pandemia con varios países
para Perú sobre todo Sí claro y también
en chile para ayudar a que los
venezolanos que perdieron sus trabajos
durante la pandemia y no tenían como
sobrevivir pudieran tener estos vuelos
humanitarios de gratuitos para regresar
a Venezuela pero yo creo que algo
importante que tenemos que destacar aquí
es que la mayoría de los venezolanos se
fueron de Venezuela No necesariamente
quieren regresar están tratando de
buscar un país donde puedan trabajar y
tener una vida digna y establecerse o
por un tiempo o unos años mientras que
la situación en Venezuela mejora o
quedarse en otro país entonces allí el
gobierno mexicano lo que puede hacer es
respetar el derecho mexicano y
internacional de Refugio de no regresar
a personas que no quieran regresar a su
país de origen donde algunos de ellos se
puedan sentir que sus vidas están en
riesgo
puede ser que cobra riesgo de ser
perseguidos o de tratos crueles
inhumanos y en esta situación el
gobierno mexicano debería de aplicar a
más extensivamente el asilo a darles a
conocer a los venezolanos los derechos
que tiene e incrementar los fondos para
El comal que se encarga de
administrar la solicitudes de refugio y
desafortunadamente lo que está pasando
es lo contrario
como parte de sus medidas de restricción
el gobierno mexicano también ha sido
presionado a controlar el flujo de los
venezolanos en su frontera sur y
entonces ahora desde a partir de este
año en enero está pidiendo un
visado para entrar lo que hace la el
ingreso regular mucho más difícil ya que
la mayoría de los venezolanos no pueden
sacar este visado antes de entrar a
México y en México el gobierno
está desplegando los agentes del
Instituto Nacional de migraciones en la
frontera azul y a través del territorio
para aprender a detener a personas que
estén en situación irregular Y tratar de
de expulsarlas de forma expedita